The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hope everyone had
a great Veteran's Day break
yesterday, spending
it, of course,
as I check my test audience,
spending it mostly doing
your [INAUDIBLE]
research or PSETs.
But at least one
person got to watch TV.
So at least one person
got to have a real break,
and that's something
truly amazing and special.
So now we're going
to talk about SVMs.
They're pretty much the
hardest thing in 6.034.
However, in recent
years a few shortcuts
have popped up
that will sometimes
allow you to solve the question,
depending on what they're
asking for, without solving
some vast ugly set of equations
with a vast ugly
number of unknowns.
So I'm going to show
that to you guys.
I'm also going to try to
explain all the alphabet
soup that's in [INAUDIBLE]
and what all the letters stand
for because it took me a few
times going through SVMs.
It took me a few times
going through SVMs
to actually find
out for sure what
all those letters stood for.
And if you guys figure
it out first try,
that's going to be great, and
you guys will be just fine.
So let's take a look at
the problem that's perhaps
most optimized for using some
of the shortcuts to solving it
and not putting up
all the equations.
Then I will-- not
because I'm sadistic,
but because I'm being nice,
I will force you with me
to solve some of the things they
didn't ask for us to solve so
that you can see that
we can't get away
with everything without doing
some of the harder stuff.
And of course, definitely
ask questions as always,
but this time even more so.
You guys, well, if you
were looking around,
you saw nobody in this
entire lecture hall
raised their hand that they
are already set and ready
and know SVMs.
So if you have a question,
maybe everybody else does.
So let's go.
We'll start right here.
As always, pretend
that I can draw,
and that therefore all the
pluses and minuses are only
on integer coordinates.
So we are asked in this problem
to circle the support vectors.
Draw the edges of the street
and then the dotted line
in the middle that
separates them,
the separator, as a dashed line.
And then to give w and b.
So what are w and b?
Well, there's a few
important equations in SVMs
that we really
hope-- and I'm going
to tell you we're lucky in
this because we don't have to--
but we really hope
that we don't have
to use because they provide
a huge number of variables.
So one of those
crucial equations
is that for a plus support
vector, w vector dot x plus,
the plus support
vector, plus b equals 1.
w dot x minus plus
b equals minus 1.
And w dot that dotted
line-- I don't know,
we'll call it dot dot
dot-- plus b equals 0.
So what does this mean?
There are a lot of vectors.
Well, I mean, we're usually
in two-dimensional space,
so we can basically
just say that there's
two components of this
w vector, w1 and w2.
And they're just
two coefficients
in a linear equation.
So for instance, what we're
interested in finding,
this dot dot dot
line, we'll just
call that x, so
with nothing on it.
Actually, maybe
that'll be easier.
This is equivalent to saying
w1x1 plus w2x2 plus b equals 0,
where x1 is this,
and x2 is this.
We would possibly
call them x and y.
So one way to think
about it is w1,
we'll call it a, ax
plus-- call w2 b-- by.
Oh, don't call it b.
Well, ax plus cy plus b
equals-- I'll put this all in
parentheses-- this is basically
an equation like this.
Or y equals negative a
over c x minus b over c.
It's basically y
equals mx plus b.
Does everyone see that?
This thing that
we're looking for,
this w dot x plus b
equals 0, is the equation
of a line in
Cartesian coordinates.
It just looks uglier.
Normally, when we're doing
all this solving for w and b,
we would have to put
in tons of equations,
plug in all of the
support vectors in there.
And we'd have to use these
little devils called alphas.
Alphas essentially--
if it wasn't clear
in the lecture, which it
usually isn't completely
clear to everyone, wasn't clear
to me completely-- alphas,
the way I like to
think about them,
the alphas in this
problem is they
are the weight of how
significant any particular
point on the graph is towards
creating the boundary.
The higher the
alpha is, the more
that that point narrows
in the boundary.
The lower the alpha is, the
less that that point narrows
in the boundary, the
wider the road can be.
And if that point
doesn't do anything,
if that point is irrelevant
and could be removed
and it wouldn't affect the
boundary, the alpha is?
Everyone?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
PROFESSOR: Zero.
Well, that was one person, but
you can suffice for everyone.
The alpha is 0.
And that means if it's not a
support vector, if it's not
one of the vectors on
the boundary lines,
it will always have an alpha
of 0 because it doesn't affect.
So keeping that in
mind, there's a few fun
and important
equations about alphas
that we'll need if we're
solving many equations
for many unknowns, which
hopefully we won't have to do.
The sum over the
positive alphas equals
the sum over the alphas--
the negative points.
And this is true
over all the points.
But since all of
the alphas are 0,
except for the support
vectors, it also
means the alphas of
the positive support
vectors are equal to the
alphas of the negative support
vectors.
Additionally, our old
buddy, the w vector,
is equal to the
sum over all i that
are plus vectors of wi
alpha i minus m over j
minus vectors of wj alpha j.
Now, all of these equations
can be used in a bloody mess
to figure out the answer to
what we're trying to find,
which is circles--
well, actually, they
can't be used as
circle support vectors
and draw the dotted line.
But once we do that,
all these equations
can be used in a bloody mess to
give us the next thing that we
want, which is w and b.
So fortunately, there's
another way to get w and b.
If you guys really want,
at the end of the hour
we can also try to
derive w and b using
the many equations
in many unknowns,
but it's a bit painful.
We'll try to do it the cool way.
So let's start off.
This is the one
we're looking at.
We need to find where
the support vectors are.
So the first thing we need
to do is simply eye it.
Fortunately, on the
test, there will always
be ones that you can
eye if you're supposed
to circle the support vectors.
There's obviously
some number of pluses
and some number of minuses.
I say obviously, but maybe not.
But hopefully
obviously, and we'll
find out because I'm going
to call on random people.
So give me a positive
support vector.
AUDIENCE: Um, going to the one
that looked like [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Which plus
sign, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: One on the right.
PROFESSOR: The one all
the way on the right.
Yeah, that plus sign is a
positive support vector.
That's good.
All right?
Excellent.
Now, give me a negative
support vector.
That one?
No?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sorry.
PROFESSOR: Ah, no problem.
Give me a negative
support vector.
AUDIENCE: I should
definitely ask
you, what's a support vector?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: That is
a good question.
The question is, what
is a support vector?
How many other people will
admit to having this question?
See?
You're not alone.
OK.
Before I go on, I'm going
to assume-- you guys make
sure I'm correct-- Monday
was, just being sure
so I can tailor based on this.
Monday was the support
vector machine lecture.
But it was also very
difficult to follow.
That's what I usually expect.
So what is a support vector?
Well, all these pluses and
minuses, if we were me,
and if, I guess--
yeah, if we were me
and if I was describing this
problem, the one that we work
out in class, I would
call them points
because they're on the graph.
They're points.
They're data points.
But however, in more difficult
versions of this problem
that have n
dimensions, where n is
some ridiculous
number of dimensions
that you're never
going to graph.
Like say some of the
research I'm doing now,
I could use support
vector machines
on some of these articles that
I'm reading about cyber events
to try to figure out
if there's a real event
or if it's just someone
complaining about how we're
really vulnerable or
something like that
and no event actually happened.
So the reason why they
call these guys vectors is
when you're not able to graph
them on a Cartesian plane,
there's still this long vector
of many different dimensions.
Right now, though, these
points represent the vectors.
This is very simple.
It's easier to
view them this way.
But for instance, that
plus at negative 1, 2
represents the
fact that there is
a vector going in the
direction of negative 1, 2
with a magnitude such that
it reaches negative 1, 2.
So all these points are
just a point representation
of a vector.
You probably, in any class
that worked with vectors,
saw this, saw vectors being
represented as points.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Always from the
respect to the origin?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The question is always
with respect to the origin.
The answer is
canonically, when vectors
are represented as
points, yes, it's always
with respect to the origin.
So that's the basic idea is that
all these points are vectors.
So what are support vectors?
Well, you could call them
support points for this case.
But the reason we call
them support vectors
is again, in the
generalized case
that you might be doing in
the real world with real AI,
you're going to
have a giant vector.
And it's not just going
to be points on a graph.
Well, usually.
So the support vectors,
the support points,
we found one of them correctly.
It's this guy.
They're going to be the
ones that again, they
don't have an alpha of zero.
They're the ones that bind
in the, as Petra calls it,
the road, the boundary lines.
They're going to be
on the edge of plus.
Whichever direction
we draw it, this plus
is the edge of the plus region.
If we made this the
edge of the plus region
and everything on this
side is plus and everything
on this side is
minus, we'd be screwed
because there's two pluses
on the other side of that.
Generally, when trying
to find a support vector,
you do something a little bit
similar to my crazy method
of doing nearest
neighbors, and try
to find a plus-minus pair
that's close to each other.
Sometimes though, it's
not just two points
because sometimes if you try
to draw the simple-minded
thing, which is
the perpendicular
bisector of the two points,
you get screwed because there's
another point in your way.
So now that I've
given away a clue,
let's go-- and hopefully
that made sense to you guys.
The support vectors are
the ones on the edges that
are just barely a plus
for sure, or just barely
a minus for sure.
Let's go back.
Can you give me a
negative support vector?
AUDIENCE: The top one?
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: The top
negative point?
PROFESSOR: The one
on the top left?
Yes.
And does anyone think that
there's a third support vector?
Well, let's simple-mindedly
try the thing that-- remember,
support vectors
always attempt to have
the widest possible space
between the pluses and minuses
that they can.
So let's simple-mindedly try to
do the perpendicular bisector
and see if screws us over.
So when we simple-mindedly do
the perpendicular bisector,
it goes through here like this.
And it's just fine.
So these are the only
two support vectors.
And there's our divider line.
So we're on the home stretch.
But we have to find w and b.
In olden days, we would find
w and b by plugging in w dot
the plus support
vector, plus b equals 1.
Oh, that's very crucial.
These w dot x plus
x minus are only
true equaling 1 or negative 1?
Or only true for
support vectors?
It's always true that w dot
any positive point plus b will
be some positive number.
But it won't always be 1.
In fact, it will always be
greater than 1 up over here.
It will always be less
than -1 down over there.
In olden days, we would plug
in -1, 2 into this equation.
We would plug in 3,
-2 into this equation.
We'd plug in alpha plus equals
alpha minus in its sums.
And since there's
only 1 plus 1 minus,
we'd know they were equal.
And then we'd fidget around
with this w equation.
However, there is a
better way to do it.
And so let's use
this cheap strategy
to solve this
version of the SVM.
Here's how.
First, and I know I didn't
draw these completely straight.
Sorry.
But can anyone, by looking
at-- this is three, -2.
2 And this is -1, 2.
Can anyone tell me what
the equation-- you can do y
equals mx plus b.
Can anyone tell me what the
equation of the dotted line
is supposed to be if
I was good at drawing?
AUDIENCE: [SEVERAL ANSWERS]
PROFESSOR: People say
y equals x minus 1.
And I say yes, y
equals x minus 1.
So therefore, the
pluses would be
y is greater than or
equal to x minus 1 indeed.
So we've already seen that
w dot x plus b somehow can
be converted into this form.
Right?
So therefore, if we
have y equals x minus 1,
then we know that we have we
have w dot x plus b equals 0.
Let's do that here.
So we know that w1 x1.
We can even call it x and y.
I think it'll be fine.
No one will come after us.
w2 y plus b equals 0.
But we also know that
y equals x minus 1,
which means that if
then according to this
thing we have over here,
then negative w1
over w2 equals--
So we know that negative w1 over
w2-- and we have -b over w2.
So y equals x minus 1.
And if we solve this equation
to make it look like this,
we would have y equals negative
w1 over w2 Minus b over w2.
So we know that in some way,
shape, or form-- we know that
then therefore, w1
over w2 is some scalar
multiple of minus 1.
And we know that b over w2
is, in fact, some scalar
multiple of positive 1.
Scalar multiple, what's
a scalar multiple?
Well, why is it a
scalar multiple?
Why isn't it just going to
be negative 1 or positive 1?
Just because in
this equation, we
can multiply the entire
equation by any number
and it will still have
the same boundary line.
You guys see that?
Oh, there's an x here.
If we multiplied everything,
since it's all divided by w2.
If we double w2, but
also doubled b and w1,
it would be the
exact same equation.
Do you guys agree?
So there's, in fact, infinitely
many possible equations.
You say, well, great, Mark.
You've figured out
what form it is.
So you figured out
that w1 over w2
equals some scalar
multiple of negative 1.
So it's negative
1 times-- what's
everyone's favorite letter?
AUDIENCE: k.
PROFESSOR: k.
Negative 1 times k.
And we figured out
that b over w2 is--
I guess we can just do
negative -- is positive k.
But what's k?
How are we going
to figure it out?
Well, it's a good question.
And I will tell you how.
I will assert the following
fact as true without proof.
Then I will not prove it.
1 over the magnitude of w,
which is this vector here
with w1 and w2,
equals this where
this is that line that I
just drew, the line from here
to this point.
1 over the magnitude
of w equals this.
Therefore, since 1 over the
magnitude of w equals this,
and this equals, I
believe, 2 root 2,
because we're going
over to, down to,
Pythagorean Theorem, 2, root 2.
So therefore, flip
everything over.
Magnitude of w equals
1 over 2 root 2.
So therefore, magnitude
of w equals root 2 over 4.
But why are we OK?
Well, how do we calculate
the magnitude of w?
Do people know, in general,
magnitudes of vectors?
Generally, for these
vectors, we do it
by the square root of the sum
of the components squared.
So the square root of w1
squared plus w2 squared
equals root 2 over 4.
But that's not all.
That's not all, we say, because
we know from this over here
that the ratio of w1 and w2 is--
AUDIENCE: [SEVERAL ANSWERS]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
ratio of w1 and w2
is going to be--
actually, sorry.
I shouldn't put a k here.
I realize I probably have
been confusing you guys a lot.
w1 over w2 is just -1.
B Over w2 is just 1.
That's just a fact.
There's no k.
The k is to determine
what w1 and w2 are.
So w1 equals -k.
And w2 equals positive k.
And b equals also positive k.
By the way, here's
a question for you.
Could I have put the
negative sign on w2 and b
instead of on w1?
So many people said yes.
That's a very smart answer.
Actually, no,
because of the fact
that the pluses are on
the negative x-axis.
It's just a little
trick I picked up.
When one of them is negative
and the other one isn't, follow
the pluses.
So we know that w1 is
-k, w2 is positive k,
and b Is positive k.
w1 over w2 is -1.
b over w2 is positive 1.
So what do we know about
the ratio of w1 and w2?
It's equal to -1.
And that means that
when we square it,
w1 squared equals w2 squared.
So therefore, this
is the square root
of 2 w1 squared, which
equals root 2 w1.
Well, actually no, it
doesn't equal root 2 w1
because w1 is actually negative.
So it's negative root 2 w1.
It doesn't matter.
The point is that if that
equals root 2 over 4,
then w1 is-- everyone?
AUDIENCE: Negative 1/4.
PROFESSOR: Negative 1/4.
Bingo.
And if w1 is -1/4, 1 everything
else falls into place.
What are w2 and b?
Everyone?
AUDIENCE: Positive 1/4.
PROFESSOR: Positive 1/4.
We got it.
We're done with this
part of problem.
However, bonus.
Let's come to the
alphas, which they
didn't ask you to calculate.
Actually, you know what?
We'll do the alphas if
we have enough time,
since they didn't actually
ask you to calculate them.
However, my recommendation
is since there's only
one alpha-plus and
one alpha-minus,
they must be equal
from this equation,
since the sum of the alpha-plus
equals the sum of alpha-minus.
And so therefore, w equals
the sum of w-- sorry,
this should be an x.
Of course, there's not a
million w's in this equation.
The sum of the positive data
points times their alpha
is minus the negative data
points times their alphas.
So we're looking at here
-1/4, 1/4 equals-- what
do we got here?
Positive point negative 1, 2?
So we've got alpha, alpha of
that point negative 1, 2 minus
alpha of that minus point.
And what is that?
It's 3, -2.
3, -2.
So if both of the alphas
which are equal were 1,
we'd have -4, 4.
But we want -1/4, 1/4.
So actually both of
the alphas are 1/16.
And that's the answer.
We'll do that more in
depth if we have time.
But we won't.
So let's do number two.
So let's go into faster mode.
Number two, very similar
to number one in many ways.
But as you can see, one of the
main things that they added
an extra minus sign at 2, -1.
So I think we can all
agree that this will still
be our plus-- Actually, they
added another plus sign there,
too.
So maybe this plus sign
is a support vector.
But it's not.
This plus sign is
a support vector.
What do you guys think
about the new negative sign?
Will it become a support
vector since it is strictly
closer to the pluses?
Yep, you're right.
OK, so this is a very
beautiful division
because if I do this correctly,
which I didn't, but if we
pretend that I did.
Then the dotted line is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: y equals x.
OK, so with the dotted
line at y equals x, then
just like we did up here, we
know that if y equals x plus 0,
we know that first
of all, b equals 0.
Second of all, we know
that if y equals x, then
we know that -w1
over w2 equals 1.
The pluses are still
on the left and up,
so we know that w1 is
some negative number, -k,
and w2 is some
positive number k.
Great.
How are we going
to figure it out?
Well, let's call
this d for distance,
or whatever you want to call it.
So 1 over w equals d.
d In this case is not 2 over 2.
Can everyone tell
what d is here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's actually--
so it goes over 2 and 1.
So it should be 1 1/2 root
2 since this width distance,
which is twice as much,
goes over 3 and 3,
which is 3 root 2.
So it's 1 1/2 root 2.
I don't like putting in
decimals and stuff there.
So we'll say that 2
over magnitude of w
equals 2d equals 3 root 2.
So therefore, right,
Pythagorean, one, two, three,
one, two, three, 3 root 2.
So therefore, magnitude
of w equals-- let's see.
Switch them over.
We should get root 2 over 3.
And if magnitude of
w is root 2 over 3,
we can do our same
trick from before,
square root of 2 w2 squared
equals root 2 over 3.
And this is just root 2 times
w2 equals root 2 over 3.
So therefore, w2 is?
1/3.
And w1 is?
-1/3.
Bingo.
We've got w1.
We've got w2.
We know that b was zero
because obviously it's 0.
It's y equals x.
And we're done.
That was fast.
The alphas might taken longer.
Actually, the alphas on this one
are more of a pain in the ass
than anywhere else because
let's take a look at this one
if you can see it.
We've added in yet
some new points.
We've got this point up here
and this point down there.
So I think pretty clearly
this plus and minus
are the closest to each other.
But what happens if we
take the perpendicular
bisector between these
two and do like this?
This plus is in the middle.
So therefore, this
plus is going to have
to also be a support vector.
So we can't just draw this line.
We have to include this.
What's our best division?
Vertical lines, that's right.
Vertical lines just so.
And that means that the
equation of our boundary,
the dotted line here, y-axis.
So the equation of the boundary
with the y-axis, then b
equals 0.
And hell, w2 equals 0.
So the only thing that is not--
AUDIENCE: Wait, w1 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: w2 equals 0.
So w2 equals 0.
b equals 0.
But w1 is not equal to
zero because it's just
the equation of the y-axis.
So we therefore know
that the equation is just
w1 times x equals 0.
So it's w1 times x equals 0.
And we know that that
just means essentially
that x is going to be some k.
It's also going to be
negative because of the fact
that the pluses are
still on the left.
Then we're going to have to
figure out what that k is.
We'll use our old trick-- by
this point old, hopefully.
One over magnitude
of w equals d.
This time d is just 1.
So therefore, magnitude
of w equals 1.
There's only one component in w.
So therefore w1 is
AUDIENCE: -1.
PROFESSOR: -1 because
the plus is on the left.
Do people see that?
Not too bad.
This one's easy to
calculate the w.
But it's not as easy
to get all the alphas.
But let's move on to
a new and even more
fun-- maybe not-- question,
which is this guy.
As you can see-- well maybe not.
This is a one
dimensional vector.
These vectors only have
a single dimension.
So it just looks like
a number line here.
That dimension varies from it
looks like -9 to positive 9.
It just has one component.
You don't have to worry about
any of these crazy magnitudes
with two components,
just everything
as a single component.
However, it's obvious
that a linear basis
line is going to completely
screw us up here,
since lines at this point
are just like, grunk,
all these are pluses.
All these are minuses.
Well, great, that
doesn't get them all.
So how are we going to do it?
Well, we're going to use what
is usually perhaps the hardest
thing in SVMs, but
in this case is not
going to be too bad for us.
We're going to use a kernel.
Now, based on how little
I understood kernels
the first time I
took this class,
I'm guessing that
you guys would like
to have some explanation
on these kernels.
You probably saw them.
You remember the kernels from
Patrick's lecture vaguely?
There's this phi.
And then there's this k.
And then they get
really complicated.
OK, so here's how
the kernel works.
The basic idea is this.
And I'll write it over here.
Oh, wow, there's more stuff.
OK.
I'll write it right here.
The basic idea is this.
We're taking the normal space,
which is this number line
or it could be any
kind of normal space,
and we're going
to take a vector,
we're going to put into
it a function called phi.
And phi of vector x brings
x into some new dimension.
Phi, or "phee" if
you like it better,
is usually a nasty piece
of work and something
you never, ever want to look at.
Sometimes it's not too bad.
Phi is the function that brings
it into the new dimension.
OK?
And when you brought the
data into a new dimension,
sometimes you can just cut a
straight line in that dimension
and you'll just be happy.
However, something
that was noted
by the very, very smart inventor
of support vector machines
is that you don't actually
need to work with function phi,
even if phi is an absolutely
horrible monstrosity, because
of the fact that you never need
to know what all these vectors
x actually are in the new
space, at least not directly.
In none of these
equations up here
do we ever use x by itself.
However, we do use x being dot
product with something else.
So he figured out a very
sneaky and excellent shortcut.
OK, so-- oh, I
shouldn't use x1 and x2.
I'll use x and z.
So if you have two
vectors, x and z, which
are in a regular
space, you put them
into this function
called the kernel.
Then it will tell you
phi x dotted with phi z.
And if you have that,
you don't need phi.
Does everyone see that?
Does everyone see why
we don't need phi?
Look at all these
equations up here.
We have never looked
at x by itself
in these vector
equations at least.
Now, calculating alphas, yeah,
that gets a little bit fuzzy.
Also, you may ask,
why would you do this?
You can't calculate the alphas.
It turns out that actually,
other than for these very
simple linear problems,
human minds cannot calculate
the alphas.
In fact, you run
a very complicated
quadratic optimization.
In fact, finding
out the best alphas
is the thing that you
hill climb on when you're
doing SVMs in the real world.
You say, all right,
I'll run my algorithm
when I know there's
only one peak, which
is very, very good because
it's quadratic optimization.
Let me figure out the alphas.
So in fact, it doesn't
matter that you
can't use these alpha equations
to figure out the alphas if you
only know the kernel
function and not
the phi function because
normally, the computer
figures out the alphas for you
with quadratic optimization.
Just in these
simple problems, we
know you can
calculate the alphas.
So we have the kernel,
which basically gives us
the dot product of the
things in the new space.
So being that as it may, I'll
give you the kernel here.
I'd like you give me phi.
Someone got an idea, whose
name was Susan Q. Random
Student, apparently.
She got an idea that if we had
a kernel for x and z-- actually,
they're not vectors, I guess.
There just single components.
And the kernel equals cosine Pi
over 4x times cosine Pi over 4
z plus sine Pi over 4x
plus sine Pi over 4z.
So that is the new dot product.
Oh, wait, sorry.
I put one of the z's not
inside the parentheses.
That was silly of me.
So cosine of the
quantity pi Over 4x times
cosine of the quantity Pi over
4z plus sine of quantity Pi
over 4x plus sine of quantity
Pi over 4z is the new product.
So that begs the question.
This is an easy one so
we can calculate the phi.
What is phi of x?
We're actually taking
it from one dimension
and we may be playing around
with it a lot to get this.
And this thing has
become a new dot product.
It replaces dot product.
And remember, the dot
product for scalars
would have just been multiplying
two numbers together.
So it actually makes it a
little bit more complicated.
Does anyone think
they know the phi?
Oh, we got one.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You mean two common
vectors, two dimensional?
AUDIENCE: The two points.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
That's exactly correct.
How would you have solved
this on the actual quiz
if you're not our
brave volunteer?
Well, that k, if you squint at
it-- not very much actually--
is pretty much a dot product
between cosine of Pi over 4
and sine Pi over 4.
I mean, look at it.
Remember, if the dot
product of x and z vectors
is x1, z1 plus x2, z2-- so that
basically is x1, z1 plus x2 z2.
Oh, this should
have been a times.
Yeah, this should
Sorry.
There's a plus there.
Anyone who missed it
because of that, my bad.
That's should have been a times.
That should have been
a times up there.
It's cosine Pi over 4x cosine
Pi over 4z plus sine Pi
over 4x times sine Pi over 4z.
So yeah, it's basically
the dot product
between cosine Pi over
4x and sine Pi over 4x.
Bingo.
All right, last thing.
Well, we're not done
yet because we're going
to maybe ask some questions.
And then we're going to see if
we can calculate those alphas.
But last thing, let's
graph in this new dimension
all the points.
So obviously, cosines
and sines, so we're
going to get results
between 1 and -1.
Let's see.
Maybe I can graph it--
did I write on all these?
Wait, maybe this one.
No, people drew weird
stick figures there.
OK.
Oh, yeah, this
one's kind of messy.
But we'll do it on this.
OK, so this is 1, -1, 1/2,
-1/2, 1, -1, -1/2, 1/2.
OK?
So given that,
let's try to graph
all these points
on this number line
into this brave new dimension
by using their cosine times
Pi over 4.
So all right, great.
So let's do the pluses first.
The plus at 0 is
cosine 0, sine 0.
So what is that?
AUDIENCE: 1, 0.
PROFESSOR: That's 1, 0.
That's right.
In fact, the 8 and the
-8 are also that times 3.
The 8 and the -8 are also
that because then it's
just 2 Pi minus 2 Pi, which both
cosine and sine are periodic.
OK, great.
What about the 1?
Well, that's cosine Pi
over 4, sine Pi over 4.
And what's that?
AUDIENCE: [SEVERAL ANSWERS]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's root
2 over 2, root 2 over 2.
So that's something
like here, we'll say.
And in fact, and the 9
and the -7 are also that.
So there's three of these two.
What about the -1?
That's cosine negative pi
over 4, sine Pi over 4.
AUDIENCE: [SEVERAL ANSWERS]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
The x value is
positive root 2 over 2.
And the y value is negative.
And again, there's
three of them.
All right, great.
Now let's do the minuses.
There's the minus
at 3, which is also
the same as the minus at -7.
The minus at 3 is cosine 3
Pi over 4, sine 3 Pi over 4.
Which one is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's going
to be in the second quadrant.
The cosine is going
to be negative.
But the sine is
going to be positive.
And so we get 3 points here.
And as you may have predicted,
the other one, the 5 Pi over 4,
is in the third quadrant.
We get 3 points here, Where
are the support vectors?
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Question?
AUDIENCE: I understand
where you're
getting at the three
quantities of pluses
in the first of the quadrants.
But according to the
[INAUDIBLE] line there,
you want that the total of
four-- maybe the values.
PROFESSOR: Oh, you're right.
There's only two.
Good call.
There's two negatives here.
And there's two negatives here.
Good call.
It doesn't change the problem.
In fact, if we just
graph more points,
there might have been more.
But that's a very subtle
and important distinction.
There are two negatives.
But otherwise, yeah, these
are graphed correctly.
Does anyone see where
the support vectors are?
AUDIENCE: The first two.
AUDIENCE: Maybe the top two.
PROFESSOR:So the top
two, the minus and plus.
We'll try to do the
perpendicular bisector.
Let's see it.
That works.
But guess what?
These guys are on the same line.
So we'd better circle them.
So actually, the question is
what isn't a support vector?
Only this.
Only those three.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you have
just done this in one dimension?
I mean, you just showed that
those ran on the same lines.
So you really didn't need the
cosine term and a sine term.
You could have proved all
this with just the cosine.
PROFESSOR: All
right, the question
is couldn't we have done
this in one dimension.
All we do is only the cosine.
So if we did only
the cosine, then they
would've still been
easily divisible.
The answer is,
absolutely, we could have.
However, the question did not
because Susan Q. Random Student
decided to do cosine and sine.
But yes, if we had said
you, [INAUDIBLE] student,
find a phi that
will work for this,
you could have found a
phi that was just cosine.
That would have been easier.
However, it's important to
be a little work with what
somebody else gives you.
In this case, they gave you
that transformation, which yeah,
was wasteful with
an extra dimension.
You didn't need the
sine because you didn't
need the y-axis really here.
You just needed the x.
Does everyone see
this, how this works?
You can maybe
transform dimensions?
The main hardest part is
they'll usually give you a k
and ask for a phi or give
you a phi and ask for a k.
But it's not too bad.
Just remember, if
they give you a phi,
do a dot product with it.
And if they give
you a phi that's
just one component, dot
product of one component,
just multiply them together.
Easy enough.
If they give you a k,
treat it as a dot product
and try to reverse engineer.
It's usually something
like this that's
easy to reverse engineer.
I really haven't seen
it where it's not.
So it often looks like
the scariest problem.
But it's usually not too bad
to go between phis and k's.
Does anyone have any
questions on anything
that we did on support
vector machines?
Question.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
intuition behind the w?
We solved it and figured
out numbers and integrations
with it.
But what is it in relation to--
PROFESSOR: Question
is, what is intuition?
What is w?
W Is the dividing line.
It is the drop
dead dividing line.
When I say the drop
dead dividing line,
you like those big, bold
solid lines over there.
Those are your
pretty certain lines.
Everything past
that was a minus.
In your training,
it's that everything
past the big bold line there was
a plus in your training stuff.
But the dotted line is
the one you're really
going to use in the test data.
In the test data, when
push comes to shove,
you might get something if
it's inside of that gutter.
And if it's on the,
say, of that one
up there, if it's on the upper
left side of that dotted line,
you're going to call it a plus.
So that dotted line is
your decision boundary.
And that is basically the idea.
And in fact, the way that
the algorithm would do it
on the computer is it
would quadratically
optimize the alphas,
which messes around
with the dotted line.
And by quadratically
maximizing the alphas-- you see
how the alphas add up to a w.
It just checks it around.
And eventually, it finds, oh,
making the alpha of this one 0
makes it a better optimization.
You're trying to get the
widest possible road.
It would eventually
come out to this.
This is trivial for
a human to eyeball.
But some real
problems with 200 data
points that have to get one or
two of them wrong, classified,
and you may be using a
quadratic kernel or something
that, you can't do that.
You just can't.
Well, maybe can,
in which case you
should be getting a
MacArthur Fellowship
or something like that.
But the computer can.
And the basic idea is
when it comes down to it,
it figures out the alphas, that
the best w for the widest road.
And the w s your
decision boundary.
Good question.
Any other questions about
our old friend, SVM?
I have a question for you.
After seeing this-- and
let's pretend that they only
asked to solve for w's, b's,
these kind of kernels and phi,
which are the typical
things-- how many people now
think that you can go through
and work an SVM problem?
All right, we've got a few.
We've got a happy few.
Band of brothers.
Maybe eight people
raised their hand there.
That's good.
How many people know what
a support vector is now?
That's really good.
Because if that's all
you learned from today's
recitation, it's still good.
It really is.
I'm telling you.
I had to take two classes on
this and then TA it before I
really, really understood it.
So you guys are ahead of me.
All right, take care.
Have a great weekend.
And we'll see you for boosting
and vampires next week.